[Music]
hey welcome back everybody this is a
chest for Knights or a class here at the
st. Louis chess club every Sunday from 2
p.m. to 3 p.m. and today we're going to
be discussing about a very typical
sacrifice the sacrifice on h7 which can
create a lot of problems for your
opponent if executed correctly so let's
get it going this is the position guys
you're going to be white I want you to
think for a little bit and try to
calculate all the way until the end I
know some of you already know the answer
and this is once again very very typical
sacrifice but a lot of you don't know it
so take some time think about it think
about some typical features of this
position and then start calculating
yes one question what are some some
typical features of these positions what
can you tell me interesting about the
position very good white has a space
advantage yes mm-hmm very good so the
Knights cannot get closer to the king
and therefore a defender King right
defending the potential maneuver with
the night on g5 which gets once again
another attacker closer to the black
King right anything else that's about it
the Queen is excellently placed
yeah despite the fact that it hasn't
moved it's not developed as we would say
it actually is developed because it's
ready to jump immediately on the Kings
side and put more pressure on the King
so all our forces are attacking the King
the beach this bishop this bishop this
Knight this Queen they're all
contributing to the same goal and that
is to checkmate the black King how many
defenders does black have
yes hmm zero zero defenders I mean I
would give him one defender it's pretty
close to the king right the rook the
Queen could potentially be considered
the defender but okay it's protecting
this square but unfortunately it's not
enough yeah if this bishop wouldn't be
here then the Queen could potentially be
considered the defender as well but yes
I would give it for the moment only one
defender to black so now let's try to
calculate and what I'm trying to when
I'm saying calculate I want you guys to
visualize the whole variation in your
head and I want you guys to give me the
whole variation with ramifications along
the way with other options for your
opponent and how are you going to finish
him off in all of those options
no the first movies actually Bishop
takes f7 so he was right the sacrifice
on h7 Knight to g5 is definitely a good
move a very interesting move the problem
is I'm just simply going to defend
you're attacking my pond on h7 but your
attack is not as fast as it could be so
now I have time to bring my defenders in
well bring potentially bring my
defenders into the game for once I can
just simply play this move h6 I can also
play this move g6 with the same idea
defending the pawn on h7 right so
there's plenty of differences and of
course you still have the space
advantage you still have the better
chances in my opinion you could
potentially do something like Queen g4
prepared the Queen lifts on the 4th rank
attack the pond on h7 bring your forces
closer closer the King and then you're
still going to have the advantage but in
this particular case you actually have a
way to just get a decisive advantage
immediately yeah
[Music]
all right Bishop takes h7 let's try to
calculate Bishop takes h7 yeah go on
King takes h7 Knight g5 check all right
let's see it on the board now black has
a few options right he has four options
some of them are better than the others
two of them are very easy to be solved
hmm so I'm going to start with this one
this is the easiest one to be solved and
I want somebody that hasn't answered yet
yes yellow in the back Queen to h5
absolutely King to g8 Queen h7 checkmate
yeah that's it that was the easy one
of course now what if I go to h6 this is
pretty easy as well yes yes
ix except seven and that's actually a
double check very good
both the bishop and the knight are
attacking are checking the king the king
has to move then we're just simply going
to capture the Queen that's going to be
game over yeah is the conversion after
that so okay let's get to the more
serious options for black
let's go King GA
and what I want you guys is for one of
you to give me the whole variation from
beginning to the end if possible till
the checkmate so whenever you raise your
hand be sure to have the whole
one-two-three four-five-six smooth so
quite a few you have to have everything
planned
not not to you because I know you know
not you for the moment because I know
you know and you already answered so
somebody that hasn't tried their hand at
it
be sure to know the whole thing okay so
calculate visualize visualize the whole
variation in your hand
do I see a hand in the back still
thinking okay you already answered and I
know you know it
and I see some tentative raises of hand
and then they go back down very quickly
come on
calculate the whole thing be sure about
your answer and then just give it to me
yes Queen h5 go on continue what is
black going to do
if he's gonna do that then we have a
winning position at least from a
material point of view we have a winning
position yeah we're just simply going to
retake with the bishop now we're going
to have a queen for two pieces for two
nights a queen and a pawn for two nights
so that's definitely enough material to
consider it a decisive advantage well
he's gonna go cook - yay
what are we going to do now the whole
thing Queen takes f7 King to h8 continue
lower your hands
continue come on
now it takes c6 now I would say this is
underperforming this is an
underperforming move because I think I'm
simply going to defend with Queen e7 you
don't have the checkmate on g7 so now
what you can do you can still check
though here and then you attack both my
rooks of course you're still going to
get a decisive advantage more or less I
can go rook f8 you take this route but
now your knight is a little bit out of
play yeah and potentially I'm going to
be able to attack it and then capture it
and if I manage to capture it them I'm
starting to have some chances at least
right now you have a much better
alternative much much better yes Queen
to h5 the whole thing I go king a king
g8 only move nope again underperforming
underperforming move I'm going to go
Queen to e7 the same thing and now what
I assumed you had in mind was Queen to
h8
but then the problem is the consequence
of you moving the Queen from h5 to h8 is
that the knight on f7 is no longer
protected so that's you know that's just
going to be actually losing for you for
white yes what is your question
I'm going to do the same thing King to
g8 actually you know what if you go
Queen g6 I might even have a better
alternative I might be able to go knight
of fate bringing the knight of Defense
right what are you going to do now you
can go knight of seven button I go King
g8 and then if you take my queen I take
your queen
yeah so that might not again
this is you have such a strong option
here that everything else just pales
into comparison with way with this one I
know most of you know it but I want some
somebody else somebody else maybe
Queen to h5 is the first move King to g8
continue now ask yourselves why did you
take this point on up from f7 why did
why did you decide to do that first and
not just you know continue with checks a
different path a different route
okay
behind you
you know okay yellow h7 there's no pawn
going to h7 Queen h7 yeah thank you go
into h8 okay moves here
Queen takes g7 and that's a checkmate
and now we see that the absence of the
pawn on f7 is crucial yeah that's why we
took the pond on f7 first this is
checkmate
everything is forced so we solved King
g8
what if you go is king g6 now I think we
have a few options but let's see which
one is the best there's a few ways of
attacking yeah Queen d3 is one way
the problem with Queen the tree is that
I'm simply going to go at five this is
my only move my only defensive move and
yep this is a very very well-known
pattern the whole position is a very
well-known pattern so you should
probably remember it as accurately as
possible yes you can go Queen g3 and now
you're reinforcing your thread yeah but
I think even easier maybe in this
position could be to go Queen g4 first
yeah the same thing if it goes a5 you
can go Queen jittery so I agree with
that another way h4 very good the same
idea right you're trying to attack the
king you're trying to displace the king
from this fairly safe Square yeah you
would love to put the King on h6 to
force the king to go to h6 because then
a lot of discovery checks are going to
become a possibility
so after h4 okay I'm going to go work to
h8
how about this move
is this a good move today I'm not even
sure if this is a good move
actually it's not no no no this is a
good move guys this is a good move but
think up try to understand why what what
happens after the only move which is
rotates the tribe sure this might not be
a good
mmm yeah you have a way you have a good
way of of winning a lot of material but
I think there's only one precise way of
doing that and you have options so
there's a lot of ways to display this
position
yeah I think if you can get a full rope
that will put you up on exchange that
should be good that should definitely be
good right
no no not to me no no no I want a full
rook I want you guys to get a full rook
in this position that will put you up on
exchange yeah because he already gave a
piece say if you get a full rook then
that's going to be up on exchange you
are a full piece down right now be
careful it's not that easy it's not that
easy because black has his his his
threats in this position black would
love to eliminate your attackers so his
next move if possible would be rook
takes d5 Bishop takes g5 Quint hd5 and
then that's going to be decisive
advantage actually for black yeah he's
going to have three pieces for look
that's huge so you have to be a little
bit careful we have to be forced as well
Queen to d3 okay as a very good start
the only good start in the position go
on Black has two options no you cannot
move to have six yeah one second yeah
f-five that's one option and the other
one King to h6 let's start with the easy
move anybody
nine takes f7 that's one checkmate Queen
h7 that's another one there's quite a
few options yeah you can also just
simply take on e6 and take the Queen but
I always emphasize the fact that you
should be precise so now don't take on
e6 and take the Queen just give the
checkmate as soon as possible so after
Queen d3 of course he's going to go f5
yeah somebody it takes f6 well I mean
the pawn was on f5 so al Allah I'll
allow you this this misstep he's going
to have to do what king takes f6 right
and now
very good queen to f3 check and that's a
double
that's a double attack that's exactly
why we baited this route to go to h5 we
basically forced it to go to h5 through
this idea of h4 h5 and now he's in big
trouble because if he's going to go king
to g6 to defend the rook Queen to f7
very good King to h6 only move once
again one one one at a time one at five
Knight takes c6 ok and this is a
discovery check you're attacking the
Queen you're going to capture that Queen
actually I think our next move is not
even capturing the Queen whatever he
puts in front of this king queen takes
g7 let's say he puts the Queen in front
we can go Queen takes g7 that's
checkmate
the Queen is pinned yeah
the Queen is pinned Queen is protected
by the knight just game over
so quite easy of course most positions
are different yeah
but the same principles apply whenever
you see your opponent kind of not having
any defenders around his king whenever
you see this formation this pawn chains
that give you the space advantage in the
center whenever you have this pair of
bishops set up nicely on these two
diagonals whenever you have your knight
ready to jump to g5 it should jump into
your into your face and say sacrifice me
the bishop on d3 will say sacrifice me
on h7 you should always remember about
that ok I guarantee you you're going to
you're going to execute the sacrifice
plenty of times and you're probably
going to be at the receiving end of it
quite a few times all right let's do
another quick one just to kind of
solidify this whole idea
and now you see another setup another
type of setup for this Greek gift
sacrifice yeah and what is the
difference compared to the previous
position what's the big difference in
the position compared to the previous
position yes
that's one yeah the pond d7 is on d7
instead of d5 the knight on d5 is well
basically they switched places yeah
right right it's a little bit different
but the same principle is applied there
is nevertheless a much more important
difference that I want you guys to spot
yes
the bishop is in front of the Queen no
no the bishop was in front of the Queen
previous in the previous position as
well wasn't it
maybe it wasn't okay you go no no no no
again the difference I want to know the
difference no no no moves I don't want
any moves right now I just want to know
the difference to the previous position
that's a big one it's a big difference I
know you know
come on it's obvious somebody tell me
all right thank you not that difficult
come on guys previously we had the
castle on right now the rookies on h1
which is huge
also the ponies on h4 already yeah
before the pond was on h2 so now Bishop
takes h7 comes naturally yeah
despite the fact that he has this bishop
on e7 so remember whenever he has this
Bishop on e7 we could potentially
prepare this Greek gift sacrifice by
moving the pawn from h2 to h4 and not
castling before yeah because we actually
need this rook King takes h7 continue
somebody somebody who hasn't answered
too much somebody around here on this
side this side is super active this side
not so much come on
want some more activity yes I see all of
you have your hands raised on this side
you tell me come on somebody
yellow in the back you have some ideas
now Green come on give me something give
me something
thank you very much Knight to g5 very
good all right trust your instincts a
bit more yeah I want more activity from
the right side of class of the class so
now the problem is if he tastes with the
bishop and he eliminates this attacker
of mine what am I going to do yes all
the way in the back mm-hmm pawn takes
Bishop H takes g5 of course because okay
you eliminated one of my defenders one
of my attackers sorry and now I'm going
to introduce another attacker the rook a
much more powerful attacker actually and
whatever you do next whether you go King
g8 or King g6 I'm going to do what let's
say King g6
[Music]
what Queen D 3 um it probably works as
well but it's far from the most from the
best continuation and now is not even
close I mean when you have the option of
taking the black King your opponent's
king for a ride closer to the center I
mean you should definitely do that so
just check him yeah get him closer to
your own to the center you know he's
going to feel very endangered and now I
guess the easiest way I think there's
quite a few ways of winning this
position of course
I don't even know which one is the
easiest
you know how to make the challenge a bit
more difficult for you guys give me a
move without a check that wins
which one g3 was the idea what's your
next move
because g3 defends the same squared that
was already defended the square on f4
right g3 is one I mean probably g3 wins
as well to be honest at this point so
many moves win I think for example Luke
h4 is one interesting move that wins on
the spot what's the point was might red
and threatening checkmate in two moves
with what and he cannot defend against
it to be honest I don't see the
difference I'm cutting this fourth rank
for his king so now what I want to do is
take control over the fifth rank by
playing the move g6 I would love to play
the move g6 next move open up my queen
and the king is just going to be trapped
if he goes g6 now the problem is he
doesn't have a square to retreat to so
I'm just simply going to go Queen Queen
to g4 and that's once again
checkmate so I don't see do you guys see
any defense against g6 no there's
absolutely no defense against g6 the
game is over so easier than that
checkmate in two moves with Czechs only
tracks or check checkmate
in two MOOCs not more than two moves
forced checkmate in two moves
I don't want your opponent to be able to
give any of his piece yeah yeah yeah no
no in the back
Queen to h3 very good if King g6 Queen
to h7 yeah
the king is checkmated if King to e4
only other move Queen to d3 checkmate
yeah Queen to f3 is not a checkmate
because I'm simply going to take your
pawn so you have to defend the pawn at
the same time of course these are just
kind of details I'm pretty sure even
Queen f3 in this position wins there
should be a checkmate here the King is
just way too exposed with that being
said once again I want you guys to try
to be as precise as possible yeah
because okay in this position maybe it
will not matter maybe it will win no
matter what
but in positions where you only have one
option that wins and all the others are
giving away or your advantage if you
don't maintain your precision then
you're going to be in trouble
[Music]